hi i'm jackson and i'm five years old i
work for tasty junior and today we're
making my favorite birthday cake
it's a vanilla
fruit cake i love to help my mom cook
my favorite food to cook is pizza but i
also love desserts
my favorite thing to do is have my mom
in the kitchen
she lets me cook and make tasty junior
video as well sometimes that i need my
mom
but i like to do elvis and myself
my mom can you help me with this
and my mom makes this cake for
everyone's birthday
every year i asked my mom to make this
for my birthday it's nobody's built
there today
but we just eat this cake for fun
is is cooking your favorite thing to do
with me
it's pizza
pizza
i make all kinds of food
sometimes when i whip the cream it's soy
somewhere that's why i wear my apron
when i put my hat on i feel like a
little stuff
when i'm cooking at home with my mom we
like to use the tasty ginger cookbook i
make all the recipes at home and it has
my name on it
i have a little brother
brother
brother blood not blood
blood
i give my little brother a piece when he
wants
but i could save most of it for me
[Music]
kids are my favorite i get 200 of those
this cake is my favorite because it's so
beautiful and it tastes good it's like
having a fruit salad on your cake
because it's so yummy
that's all it was nice meeting you guys
now i'm going to eat this delicious
cake it's my favorite cake
good job oh yes
[Music]
you